and in celebration of world autism  awareness day be sure to tune into et  canada tonight at 7 30 as we take a look  at how the entertainment industry is  working to break the stigma surrounding  autism and this one will pull at your  heart strings we're going to leave you  now with some good vibes courtesy of  post malone who met his biggest fan  andrew on his 21st birthday andrew who  has autism and doesn't like concerts so  he finds it very overwhelming so the  meeting captured by his mom was a dream  come true take care everyone bye-bye  bye-bye  nice to meet you  thank you thank you  thank you  that's so sweet i might cry thank you  nice to meet you have fun but not too  much  yeah i know i'm just like naughty  moms are cool yeah  why did things just happen here